all right let's talk about my
experiments shall we yeah let's do it
I'm excited I'm excited about this cuz I
also don't know the details I know that
you saw the text messages I saw some of
the text messages and I was very curious
okay so this is a big one um I you're
pregnant I'm
pregnant what was the one where Arnold
swarzenegger got pregnant what was
it movie I can't remember the name but
yes I know the movie basically that's I
have the same physique too um so
basically you know for for people that
that that know me or or don't quite know
me like you know i' I've I've done a
bunch of stuff in terms of being like an
entrepreneur and an investor and these
different things and one of the the hats
that I put on you know a couple years
ago was dabbling in the world of web 3
and web 3 for those untrained you know
it's cryptocurrency it's it is
decentralized internet it is nfts it's
art on the blockchain ownership right if
1.0 is read only internet 2.0 is read
right three is actually owning a piece
of what's on the play so it's a very
exciting Frontier and it and it's filled
with a bunch of explorers that I would
say are it's a small number of people in
terms of people that are excited about
digital art call it you know 250,000
people or less but it is you know a
serious group of people that are
enabling a new canvas to take form in
front of us and I believe in my heart of
hearts that for all the bad press that
see about nfts and all the scams and
don't get me wrong there's tons of that
[__] there is something true about uh if
you had to close your eyes and wake up
in 20 years will collectible digital art
be a thing of course it will right like
and the blockchain is a perfect a
perfect place to like prove provenance
to prove scarcity there's a lot of
advantages there long story short you
know I
launched something called Moon Birds
which was a pfp project I remember the
text I got on the day of that launch oh
my God so we launched this you know
collectible nft and it
skyrocketed Way Beyond what we had ever
thought so to give you all a sense from
launch to one year in over a billion
dollars has been traded in moonbird nfts
that's so wild um and I did not expect
that you know I really didn't but with
that comes trading and I have never live
the world of trading I've grown
companies to quite some size but never
publicly I've never taken a company
public MH and when you take a company
public I.E NASDAQ you know New York
Stock Exchange you deal with the ups and
downs and feedback from people that are
now stakeholders of that particular
company it's different this isn't Equity
holding nft does not make you a
shareholder it's very different but they
still pay attention to what is the price
of this nft yeah y so when the nft goes
up times are good people are happy and
when it goes down people are not happy
I've had people truly hug me and say
they've paid off their house because
they sold one of my nfts for $200,000
and they were stoked and it was like
tears kind of hugging I've had people
basically Tear Me Apart saying I am the
other person on the other side of that
equation that bought that nft for let's
Call it Whatever 50,000 not 75,000
10,000 doesn't really matter it's all
relative to how much that person has as
an individual and how are you going to
fix this because the nfts are down and
they need to go up right right and some
of it is on you know what we we build to
try and build bigger and better things
for the ecosystem and try and hopefully
prove that we are a company here for the
long term it has taken an serious
emotional toll on me as an individual
I've had many many sleepless nights I've
had anxiety like I've never had before
I've had to work with therapists and
I've had to I've had to reach out to my
primary care physician and get
anti-anxiety medicine which I've never
had to do before I have had some dark
moments with some some not dark like in
suicide but dark as in you know it's
destroyed me because I've always
considered myself an honest person I've
never been here to screw anyone over
you're also a very uh I consider you to
be an empathic feeler maybe the right
word is like you're a deep feeler I am a
feeler for sure if something like if
something like that is sitting with you
you take it very personally I remember
when you had like stomach issues for so
long oh my God IBS related issues and
that so this year I've been you know
treated multiple times for you know
these types of issues with Physicians
all kinds of things they discovered you
know the high blood pressure thing was
discovered because I have a a brain
aneurism right now that it's on the
smaller side and they're watching it and
I'm fine but those grow The more stress
you're under because the more blood
pressure that builds up the larger the
aneurysm can grow and so you know as you
can imagine all these things hit you at
once yeah and so I I felt overwhelmed I
felt like I couldn't go to work I felt
like I I kind of just needed to reset MH
you know
and huberman who I love who's been on my
podcast Andrew huberman is a top 10
podcast now oh my God killing it killing
it love that gu he's doing such a an
amazing job of executing I don't think
I've seen anyone better at doing
monologues and and the way that he can
do them about scientific topics I mean
just if you haven't subscribed to humor
podcast I mean it's along with Thea's
you know top five medical podcast to
subscribe to along with Ronda Patrick I
mean they're they're all heroes hberman
did a a couple Hour episode on ketamine
therapy mhm and ketamine
therapy you know it's used for PTSD it's
used for severe depression and it's used
for anxiety and it sounded really
interesting it rewires neurop Pathways
and huberman's episode highly recommend
I'm not a scientist but he is and he
goes in depth about what it actually is
doing on the brain and
I always thought of ketamine clinics as
being these Shady places these places
where you know there are real people
with real addictions that they treat you
know if you're hooked on everything from
amphetamines to you know any type of
serious addiction problems they see
these types of people and also people
that are about to kill themselves like
really suicidal like if you go to an
emergency room right now and you say I'm
going to end my life in the next 10
minutes they will most likely treat you
with some type of ketamine to just like
get you out of that state it's a very
common emergency room Hail Mary to like
get you back into a state of like just
being okay I don't want it in my life
right now and now we can work this out
or or take you to an institution where
you can get help M so I was never there
but I got to the point where I was like
I need to do something dramatic and
different and I need to reboot because I
can't take the comments I'm getting on
Twitter now did you see the hubin
episode organically did someone send it
to you organically came acoss it just
came across it I was like oh I've always
been interested in Kine i' heard about
Kine in in a recreational setting and
you know sadly who is a friend Perry
yeah Matthew Perry Just toxicology
report came back and said that he was on
CY when he drowned uh and but there's we
can get into why that that is in a
minute but in a yeah let's focus on your
personal experience and I'll just say
also ketamine and Jacuzzi or pools or
water do not mix ex there are multiple
fatalities don't mix those two things
well when you go into Academy and you
are literally sedating yourself to where
they can give you surgery dissociative
anesthe so what my doctor has told me
that the ceman doctor she's an emergency
room doctor that that did my treatments
is she said to me that if you came she
was a 10 year I think 10 or 15 years
emergency room doctor and she goes if
you came in and you had like dislocated
your hip she goes I would inject I would
give you what do they call a Bolis dose
is that what they call when they a Bolis
is right I mean they're giving you a lot
at once a lot at once they just like
push it all in right yeah and she's like
I would give you that to about like you
know I can't remember the exact X but it
was a multiple on what they give you for
therapy to put you under so I can get
that hip back into place and then you
wake up feeling fine unfortunately with
with Matthew Perry he took a dose that
was equivalent of subconscious fainting
falling asleep you know drowning type
dose and they said the toxology report I
read it he had that level in him that
would have put him in that state of of
of kind of like passing out right yeah
drugs and water don't mix folks don't
mix
anyway point it wasn't the fault of the
caman it was he was using it
recreationally versus Under the
supervision of a professional which is
which is what is needs so I found this
this clinic in in La they literally have
the set and setting right so they're all
about like you come in it's just
beautiful comfortable peaceful music
really relaxing reclining chairs eye
mask because it's important to go inward
it's not about just getting this therapy
and looking around the room music with
like drums and beautiful like sometimes
I I I picked my own playlist I did a
little bit more like chanting non non
you don't want like lyrics or you know
anything to distract you and they have
you hooked up to a blood pressure cuff
that measures throughout the time uh a
heart rate monitor like really
professional setting it's called Golden
afternoon is the name of the clinic in
La amazing name it's an amazing name and
the doctor there top tier you know
School emergency room doctor is legit as
they come MH I so I felt really
comfortable CU you know a lot of this is
about set and setting and comfort yeah
and safety and safety yeah so I went in
there and they I was like I'm going to
give this a shot because you know
huberman convinced me that that this can
help me with anxiety
MH and so you know I I laid down in this
comfortable chair turn on the heating
like they have a heating element in the
chair tilt you back a little bit you
know put on my noise cancelling
headphones they gave me an IV and IVs
does sound hardcore but for for people
like you and me that do IVs like or do
like blood draws like every other week
who cares like I don't care about this
[__] but it does sound how C to most
people MH they gave me an IV and you
know I closed my eyes and I went to a
place man I went to a place and it's a
beautiful place and it made me over
multiple treatments and I did eight in
total and they normally do six for
depression which is really interesting
because she said that it's typically
anxiety is harder to to treat than
depression in her experience MH and they
gave me eight in total and you two two
per week and about halfway
through the best way I can describe it
is imagine that life is a series of
crunches and I say crunches like the ab
workout okay whereas like nobody likes
to work out their abs right like and cuz
abs are like ah [__] AB day like you
know nobody wants to do that and I
didn't realize it but I had had a 35 lb
weight on my chest the entire time I was
doing ab workouts and it took that
weight off and I had and I still have
and it's been Weeks Later a bit of Grace
and lightness to the way I'm carrying
myself throughout life that is just a
piece that I haven't felt since I was
probably 10 or 12 years old were you
interacting with anyone in those
sessions or was it all internal no it's
all internal so it's headphones on music
ey mask the entire session lasts for
about an hour and a half they have a
camera that's watching you if anything
comes up one time I had my music
accidentally stop and I raise my hand
they're in there within 30 seconds they
bring you hot tea when you're done they
let you take your time to slowly kind of
like come to and then you can literally
walk out of there and carry on with your
day MH and it you know the first session
I was like okay that's beautiful second
session was a little difficult imagine
it's kind of loosening up like the
plaque in your brain and like rewiring
circuits and like it's not always going
to be easy but by the by I remember the
six session I just walked out there and
and she Dr Jen came in and she goes how
are you and I said I could run a
marathon right now I feel
amazing I feel like a a weight has been
lifted off my chest and I just it this
is such important work that you do such
important work because it's not about
being I don't there's not an addiction
to the substance I don't need to go back
some people go back for boosters
depending on what they have they have
she told me that some people that have
depression they'll come back in you know
every 3 months every 6 months she says
some people she never sees again mhm and
it kind of takes the anxiety and and
puts it pulls it apart from your body so
that you can see it for what it is which
is silliness because life is play and
and when you realize life is play and
we're all here just trying to figure out
our [__] yeah why are we taking it so
seriously yeah there's a lot that just
does not matter it doesn't matter you
can just chill man it doesn't really
matter so that we have clean drinking
water like what the [__] are we
complaining about so the the weight on
the chest was that
something that you can't put words to
that you just felt release or and you
don't need to get into details but I'm
just curious or was there content to it
were like oh no interesting wasn't
content content was beautiful I and and
I don't know if you've ever experienced
this Tim with I I've never done iasa
although at some point I would love to
try it but like I opened my eyes and it
was when the masks on and I was seeing
things that were as high of fidelity as
what we see today like right now Y where
you're like I am in a room right now and
I felt very present my dad's passed away
I felt very present with a father Source
there at times I felt very connected I
at one point I saw the entire world and
I saw how small I was and I was just
like it it immediately gave me this
sense of just like gratitude for that
being that little spe but also at the
same time not having to take and carry
the burdens of the world on me for being
that little speck and so there's bits
and pieces of that but I would say at
the end of the day when you come out of
it it's not like you had this Epiphany
it's more like Dr Jen calls it the
ketamine's time on she calls it time
time on brain how can we make this sit
and do the rewiring on your brain and
give you time on brain with the drug and
the compound and let it do its work and
so it was a lot of rendering there's a
lot of saying you do what you want to do
I don't care where you take me
emotionally mentally whatever it doesn't
really matter it's time on brain with
the compound and after a certain number
of sessions you just feel this natural
lift and lightness and it it felt like
I'm not a ballerina big surprise but it
felt like uh it felt like a little bit
of a like walking through life is a
little bit of a dance now than it is
such a struggle
H it makes me super happy man to hear
that amazing and I remember getting the
the text some of the texts from you and
I was excited to have this conversation
which we haven't had this is the first
time we're talking about it it
is